están en las calles de todo el país
pensilvania michigan illinois nueva york
frente a los repetidos llamados del
presidente de donald trump para detener
el conteo de votos estos activistas
demócratas quieren que sus voces sean
escuchadas y esperábamos este escenario
llevamos semanas preparando este
discurso porque sabíamos que la elección
iba a ser disputada así que por supuesto
tememos por nuestra democracia pero
también somos resistentes
para estos activistas no hay duda de que
joe biden debería ganar las elecciones
pero los partidarios republicanos
también se están manifestando en varios
estados en defensa les donald trump
lares ni un solo republicano ha sido
capaz de mirar ninguna de estas boletas
de correo podrían ser de marzo podrían
ser del comité nacional democrático joe
biden podría haber votado 50 veces o 5
mil veces hasta donde sabemos
en washington la capital federal algunas
voces demócratas piden un cambio en el
sistema para poner fin a estas
incertidumbres
ha llegado el momento de cuestionar
todas nuestras instituciones incluyendo
el colegio electoral estas son cosas que
deberíamos cuestionar no necesariamente
tienen sentido no es que lo tuvieran
cuando se promulgaron por primera vez
fueron promulgados en un mundo muy
diferente y por personas que también
tenían mucho poder concentrar transferir
power
cada uno con sus propios argumentos cree
que quiere proteger la democracia
americana una democracia que ha sido
duramente golpeada en las últimas horas